fiery titans excalibur and whatever the
heck this is
troll hunter's rise of the titans is the
fourth installment in the tales of
arcadia universe which include the
trollhunters show and spin-offs three
below and
wizards but don't worry if you haven't
seen them all i got you covered in this
full breakdown for rise of the titans
which has a crazy
time traveling ending and i believe
opens the possibility for future
installments even though none have been
announced and you'll want to stick
around till the very end as i'll be
going over differences between this new
timeline and the events from season one
so grab your trollhunter amulets make
sure to like and subscribe
seriously only three percent of you are
subscribed and uh definitely
don't kiss aja seven times because here
we go taking place a year after the
third installment wizards our story
begins with
well a story blinky here recites a brief
history of arcadia and i have to wonder
if he's telling this story to
us the viewer or perhaps to steve and
asha's little ones but we'll get to that
in a bit
all you really need to know is that our
protagonist jim's trollhunter amulet was
destroyed by a group of wizards known as
the arcane order
they believe that humans have caused too
much destruction to the planet and
therefore
earth needs to start from scratch but
the only way to do that is to resurrect
the three titans and unite them with the
heart stone the life force for all troll
kind
the only problem is the arcane order
needs all three of its members
bellrock skrell and nori to unlock the
genesis seals the seals which contain
the very essence of magic itself
in the third installment nari defected
from the arcane order and joined our
heroes so this sets the stage for rise
of the titans
nari is hiding with her pal dukxy in
metro city check out the movie poster
for gun robot 7 in the background which
is a fun foreshadowing of the actual gun
robot we'll see
battle the fire titan their commute is
cut short however when they're attacked
by
bellrock and scrail this is the first
big battle of the movie which sees the
two members of the arcane order
attempting to kidnap nari if they can
get a hold of her they can perform the
ritual to unlock those genesis seals
even if she's not willing to do it they
just need her
physically there with nari almost within
the clutches of the arcane order dukxy
performs a spell
switching bodies with her this buys jim
and the guardians a bit more time
speaking of jim he struggles with the
fact he no longer has
his amulet but without the amulet am i
still the troll hunter this
is his major character arc throughout
the movie is it the amulet which gives
him his powers or is it something deeper
within
as bellrock says
at the same time we get an introduction
to a piece of accordion technology that
will prove
very useful to our team they've created
a device which can stop users from
performing magic
very useful when you're going up against
wizards for those who are new accordions
are a technologically advanced race of
inorganic energy-based beings who hail
from a planet known as accuridian 5.
steve here has fallen in love with one
named asha and upon reuniting with her
in rise of titans he gives her a kiss
but this has some serious implications
once an accordion couple has their
seventh kiss
the male becomes pregnant we'll see
steve later give birth to seven children
and i don't wanna know what part of him
they came out of
with nori kidnapped the guardians of
arcadia decide what to do next they have
their headquarters in the floating
castle of camelot which was destroyed at
the end of the third installment but
seems to be partially rebuilt and
infused with accuridian technology
and if these past few hours weren't
filled with enough drama
jim finds out his mom is engaged to
walter strickler
walter is a changeling who throughout
the saga has been both
jim's enemy and mentor the arcane order
soon finds out that nari's real soul
isn't
in her body and they perform their own
incantation to reverse dukxy's spell but
right before nari is transferred back to
her original body she tells the
guardians they have to get their hands
on the chronosphere
and they have to do the ninth
configuration ninth configuration
sounds like an 80s boy band and no one
has any idea what that means lucky for
them the accuridians have fixed jim's
trollhunter amulet but when they track
down the arcane order
it doesn't work allowing the order to
summon the titans and begin the end of
the world
the amulet failed i
failed the three titans emerge in
various parts of the world the ice titan
and greenland the earth titan in brazil
and the fire titan in china
they're all making their way to the
quote center of the universe which just
so happens to be
jim's hometown of arcadia they have 18
hours to stop them before they converge
and destroy the world for good jim
thinks that the reason his amulet didn't
work was that it didn't contain merlin's
magic so he sends stewart and krell to
retrieve excalibur which has one of
merlin's magic stones
buried in its hilt they normally would
have gone to get merlin's staff but that
was destroyed
claire is sent on a mission to find the
chronosphere which was last seen in the
hands of a troll dragon known as
zhongshi he covets the chronosphere
because it holds the power of time being
able to show the past and future
of course he wants to know how he'll die
so he can prevent it from happening
it's ironic then that he'll see how he
dies mere moments before it happens
meanwhile jim and walter take on skrell
and the ice titan when they find out
that camelot's cannons do little damage
to this walking behemoth
walter ends up sacrificing himself using
an ungodly amount of explosives
it's a pretty sad ending for a guy who
just got engaged but as we'll see with
all the deaths in this film including
toby's at the very end this may not be
the last time we see everyone
walter's death is in vain however when
the ice titan merely resurrects
it seems the only way to stop these
titans is to stop whomever is
controlling them
halfway across the world nomura tries to
take down the earth titan but is also
killed in the process
it isn't until dukxy is able to
physically grab a hold of nari that he's
able to snap her out of her spell
giving the guardians control of one of
the three titans
one of the lines dukxy uses to snap nari
out of it is
no more running that's because for the
last year or so the two have been on the
run
hiding from the arcane order it's about
time they stop running
and fight which is exactly what they do
unfortunately in this epic battle both
nari and skrell are killed destroying
both of their titans in the process
now you think that would be the end of
it doesn't the end of the world require
all three titans well blinky missed an
important sticky page in his ancient
grimoire that says if only one titan
succeeds
that will be the element from which the
world will be reborn
so if only the fire titan makes it to
the heart stone the world will be reborn
in fire and ash
doesn't sound too enticing stuart
manages to bring over excalibur there's
just one
problem jim has tried to remove
excalibur from the stone before but it
didn't work
what will make it different now that's
when he remembers nari's words
that he has to use the ninth
configuration the ninth configuration
isn't
a thing it's them so they all put their
hands on the rock while jim is able to
remove the blade this allows him to
retrieve merlin's magic stone from
excalibur which he gives to stuart to
replace in the amulet and when stewart
does replace it
nothing happens that's because jim
hasn't yet realized
it wasn't the amulet that made him a
hero it was the courage he already had
inside
it's only when jim confronts bellrock
and recognizes this that the amulet
returns to him and he can finally become
the troll hunter
once again the amulet didn't make me a
hero
i already was toby also gets a fun
little character arc in the film
at the beginning he laments that he's
always relegated to being the sidekick
and is never the hero
well toby really becomes a hero when he
risks his life to save jim
using the accuridian device to nullify
bellrock's powers
i'm powerless don't worry
you get used to it bellrock is defeated
and the fire titan crumbles but toby is
crushed under the falling rubble jim and
gang
are able to say their goodbyes and in
anger argument throws the chronosphere
which inspires jim to crack it open
revealing the time stone if jim goes
back in time he could potentially
prevent toby's death
as well as all these other events from
ever happening so jim puts the time
stone in the amulet and wakes up on the
same day of episode 1 of the
trollhunters tv show but there are a few
key differences here
instead of 6 am like the tv show it's 8
am both versions have raccoons knocking
over the trash but in rise of the titans
jim is ecstatic to see toby confirming
he's alive in this timeline later on in
school jim shows his excitement for
trying out for the romeo and juliet play
while in the original timeline he barely
even knows who shakespeare is
jim sterling to come over to dinner to
meet his mom knowing the two will
eventually hit it off so already jim is
trying to shape this new timeline
he's even the one to recommend that toby
checks out the canal that canal being
the place where he first found the
trollhunter amulet which kicked off the
tales of the arcadia saga this suggests
that in this timeline toby becomes the
chosen one but it's jim's monologue he
uses to audition for romeo and juliet
that sums up the series and what it
means to be a hero
never forget that fear is but the
precursor to valor that to strive and
triumph
in the face of fear is what it means to
be a hero
now this ending can end here but i think
they've left this open for more movies
and tv shows
remember that nari said time is like a
flower meaning it branches in different
directions
imagine a troll hunter multiverse
similar to what marvel is doing the
movie also began with blinky reciting
this story
essentially proving the existence of
multiple universes
you could have different troll hunters
from different universes coming together
to fight a big
enemy i think that could be a great idea
to keep this series going but what do
you think was troll hunter's rise of the
titans a fitting end to the series and
do you want to see it continue i want to
hear your comments below
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram at think story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much